hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel and yes I did just wake up
which is why I look so tired and I also
don't have any makeup on so glossing
over that so the past week has been a GC
at Game Developers Conference in San
Francisco and I've played like maybe 12
hours of VR over the past week in total
I've probably played around maybe 20
hours or so at this point of different
kinds of VR I'm not really sure but the
ones I played the most of have been HTC
5 the psvr
and the oculus rift so obviously I've
been posting about my impressions on
social media and I thought that I would
just group together some of the most
common questions that people have been
asking me about VR and uh answer them so
the first thing that I wanted to address
is is VR actually good or is it a
gimmick and I think VR is incredible
I think PlayStation Move is a gimmick
and I think that you know the Wii monks
were kind of gimmicky but V ah is
amazing as soon as you put that headset
on you feel like you're in a completely
different environment you forget where
you are in the real world
it's it's so good and I think that you
really have to try it to see what it's
like nobody can explain it to you but
it's amazing second would be which of
the three I think is the best and that's
definitely the HTC vive I think it's the
best in pretty much every way it looks
the best you can walk around a space
because it the tracking works incredibly
well so you have quite a large space you
can walk around the input on the
controls it's pretty seamless and it
also has a camera on the front so if
you're gonna run into a wall or anything
you can see the wall and I know come up
and tell you that you're about to run
into something
I think the PS VI is the most
comfortable and it feels the lightest
Sproul by far the easiest to put on as
well the vibe is a little tough to put
on the oculus is somewhere in between
but the psvr is also the cheapest and I
think as a result it is the most grainy
of the bunch
on that note I don't like glasses but
for people who do it said that the PS VI
is the best one for people who
eyeglasses because it's just incredibly
adjustable
but do I think it's worth four hundred
dollars the price point they announced
it for absolutely yes so that would be
the one that I would've bought and I
wouldn't have bought five on oculus
probably
five is a very luxury product you can
trip over the quads do you need a big
space you need to have an open space in
a clear space and you need a PC to run
it so all up it's also an hundred
dollars so combining all of that stuff I
think vibe is the least convenient one
you basically need someone to watch you
play it so that you don't trip all over
yourself it's the best one but it's the
one that I wouldn't recommend to
consumers at this point the oculus is
somewhere in between it doesn't look as
good as survive the camera doesn't pick
up everything quite as well as the vibes
two cameras do and it's a little bit
cheaper at six articles but it's also
probably more comfortable the PS VI is
the cheapest one doesn't look as good
uses the move controllers which are
easily the worst of all of the villa's
controllers that the move control is
outdated technology I really hope that
they upgrade those sometime soon because
it's just not good enough but at the
same time it's also the one that is the
most accessible you just really need a
Playstation 4 run it and also a camera
but everything else comes in the box I
also got a lot of questions about motion
sickness
I personally I'm very susceptible to
motion sickness I get it on trains on
planes and cause I get it all the time
and I do get it more than most people
seem to with VR I played oculus dk1 and
got terrible motion sickness it was so
so bad that I have to sit down for like
20 minutes and drink water and try not
to throw up none of the retail versions
of any of these VI products that I'm
talking about have done that to me at
all been some moments where I felt a
little queasy and there was one point
where I was playing a game that I had
another appointment immediately
afterwards and I skipped it because I
didn't feel great but I think for the
most part it's the consumer release so
the official products are great if you
played oculus dk1 or DK 2 please don't
assume that the full release of the
oculus will do the same thing to you
because it won't it didn't to me so
oculus has this really good system that
I don't know if the others are doing
where they basically label if the game
is intense or comfortable or moderate
and that's how you know if you are
susceptible to motion sickness you
probably wouldn't want to play an
intense game the comfortable games
definitely didn't give me any motion
sickness at any point I've actually
never gotten it from a live game and
I wonder if that is because you're
moving around space or it doesn't feel
like you're what he is doing something
different to what you're seeing the only
time that it's really a problem for me
is if there's a game that has some kind
of strafing like you find me if I'm
strafing and then I see that the what
I'm seeing is strafing but my body is
not that really messes me up I also have
a friend who gets really bad motion
sickness playing any kind of
first-person game and she didn't at all
with the vibe either so you get motion
sickness really badly I just I just want
to say don't rule it out there's a lot
of stuff that works fine I guess a good
follow up for that is um what does it
feel like playing via for a very long
time it's exhausting I played via on
Monday last week for about five hours
straight and I was so tired and I think
that's because you're just constantly
being reintroduced to new environments
so every time you put a headset back on
you're in a completely new place you
have to look around to orientate
yourself all over again figure out
what's around you what way you're going
to go what you've come from it's it's
like traveling in that way it's just
everything is new and it feels like
you're in a different world so you
really have to adjust to that and doing
that that many times in one day like I
did it a lot that Monday and after that
I was just mentally exhausted the
longest that I played a single game hole
was an hour and that was again where I
was sitting it was tower defense it was
a tower defense game so it was obviously
one of the comfortable ones where I
didn't actually have to move but I could
look around the environment sort of see
how everything was going but it was it
wasn't moving so that didn't make me
motion sick at all and I accidentally
played an hour when I thought at
anything fifteen minutes but prior to
last week I didn't actually expect any
kind of side effects and now I am a
little concerned I was very fatigued I
was dizzy
and it definitely hits this strange
point where the real world feels surreal
now gonna go into that too in depth
because it's something that I haven't
yet grasped but I know that I'm not
alone and that other people who have
played VR feel the same pain where it's
like
nothing really feels real anymore it's
very odd I also never had any ice honest
at all I didn't have any ice tray I
didn't get any headaches so really the
only side effects were slight dizziness
and tiredness so I'm pretty sure that
eins is really all of the common
questions that I get if you have any
more feel free to leave my comments
below and all I'll answer as many as I
can but you know if you haven't already
gathered I love we are really passionate
about it I'm so excited for it to come
out and I kind of had this attitude that
anyone who doesn't like VRI thinks it's
a gimmick probably hasn't tried it you
just have to try it for yourself to
understand how impressive it actually is
please try it and then come back here
we'll talk about how great this is it
for me everyone thank you for watching
sorry I look so awful at a very big week
very tired and I'm going to go play a
bunch of the division I will see you
guys next time bye